I'm gonna tear you apart Ultron is gonna
be a badass you mark my words on that
[ __ ] to a new Avengers age of Ultron
trailer broke today and so now that's
why I'm here I don't know why you're
here to listen to me talk I guess which
I thank you for I'm here to talk about
the age of Ultron trailer the siege of
Ultron trailer it's kind of it's not a
mixed bag but I definitely do have two
points of view on it I watched it I was
like okay
age of Ultron trailer watch it again and
again the games you know you want to
pick up on everything before you start
talking about on YouTube so I'm watching
it and I'm like one of these things
there are not a lot of new scenes in
this trailer that were not in the last
moment there are a couple of new ones he
starts out Tony Stark's like this world
needs something more powerful than us
enter Ultron which is cool it shows the
mindset of what created him and Ultron
comes out roofs banners like Ultron's
like in the flesh know how the drones go
flag through the wall how did Ultron
staged that it was like all right guys
you stay behind the wall and when I say
in the flesh you come crashing through
scum great really funny you look at the
look on their face they're good Billy
you watch it
Hulk's not even gonna know it I'm gonna
be you have time to get mad you've
crumbs you don't know what I'm saying
it's gonna be funny but really this
trailer doesn't show you a lot of new
stuff the whole theory about maybe
hulkbusters being controlled by Ultron
that's why he's fighting the Hulk that's
gone you see Tony Stark in the thing
he's like beating down on Hulk
maybe Scarlet Witch is controlling Hulk
because that one scene where he turns
and I'd frame by frame do you see his
eyes a little bit more red could mean
he's being controlled could mean
something called the Hulk Buster just
punched the Hulk in the eye that
happened something tells me he's gonna
break a blood vessel so it might be that
I'll break it down like this the age of
Ultron teaser trailer was so awesome
it's just James Spader had monologues
upon monologues it sounded so cool I was
driving for a half an hour after that
trailer came out and I just listened to
it on loop I couldn't even watch it I
just listened to it in my car it was
awesome James Spader monologuing
children have been conceived on that
this one he has a couple of new lines
you know like I'm gonna tear you apart
from the insides pretty sweet but really
the trailer doesn't show us anything new
that we didn't already know however
however I'm just addressing that kinda
like if I'm like well it's a half moon
tonight not saying I prefer full moons
or new moons just addressing it's a half
moon it is what it is I think this
trailer is a good companion piece to the
first trailer which was a superior
trailer however I'm Gladys not going
Amazing Spiderman on
I don't want to know everything in
three-and-a-half minutes or less so
amazing spider-man traders you know what
I'm talking about you watching you're
like I know the movie I just saw it I
that's there are no surprises remember
the first Avengers trailer showed Iron
Man falling and then the Hulk saved him
and you grabbed on to the building and
save the day you saw the Hulk save Iron
Man so in the end of Avengers when you
send in the nuke up I was like we
haven't seen that scene that was in the
trailer where the Hulk saves him so let
me guess he's gonna send the nuke up
he's gonna fall Hulk's gonna save him
everything's gonna be right with the
world having like that didn't surprise
me it's like there's learning in this
trailer the like we're not gonna give
anything away I'm not more excited for
cuz I was already out of my mind from
the first trailer but I am glad that
certain folks in Hollywood are learning
not to show everything in the trailer I
still think that first ant-man trailer
could have been improved if they just
tweaked it a little bit because I've had
a couple of monologues a couple of
emotional moments not shown more of the
plot just had those moments it had to be
a better teaser trailer I feel like if
there was ever a summer kickoff that
could be the kickoff of kickoffs it
might just be age of Ultron it's
probably why they didn't show too much
in this trailer they're like everyone's
gonna see we don't have to sell anyone
on it let's just show them a few new
things that has some neat action scenes
so the new age of Ultron trailer have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]